[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a los
observadores de france 24 esta semana
vamos hasta japón donde un mestizo
explica como un simple control policial
del que fue víctima revela el racismo en
su país luego iremos a irán donde los
safaris están de boda estas excursiones
en 4x4 amenazan las zonas protegidas y
terminaremos con la noticia falsa de la
semana
este vídeo fue grabado el 27 de enero en
una estación de tokio en japón por
nuestro observador cuyo padre es
bahameño y su madre japonesa según él
este vídeo revela un caso típico de
perfilado racial con un fondo de racismo
un fenómeno ignorado y desconocido en su
país detestan el hecho de que me
hubieran detenido por tener rastas es
como si me dijeran que me detuvieron por
ser negro porque la rastra no se asocian
con ninguna otra raza que no sea la
negra
me dije ok tengo que grabar esto es
ridículo y soy japonés no sé por qué
tengo que tener miedo sin ninguna razón
he vivido en japón toda mi vida nací y
me crié aquí pero nunca ese sentido
copper conocida realmente a este país
el fabricante de material deportivo nike
y también la tenista japonesa de padre
haitiano naomi osaka denuncian
regularmente esta discriminación en
junio de 2020 apareció el movimiento
sapan for the black light inspirado en
el movimiento anti racista
estadounidense black lines matters
hay una forma muy obvia de racismo que
se ve sobre todo en eeuu pero aquí es
más bien lo que yo llamaría un racismo
amable es básicamente el racismo que
expresan estos japoneses pero sin ser
conscientes de que realmente están
siendo racistas en ese momento
en el canal nh k recientemente publicó
un vídeo sobre black light matters es
una caricatura y básicamente muestra que
somos gente violenta que solo destroza
cosas
hacer este tipo de cosas produce más
temores hacia los negros en este país
[Música]
pero dirigiendo
en los últimos años es cada vez más
iraníes han caído en la moda de los
safaris en vehículos todoterreno
atraviesan dunas y zonas vírgenes o
incluso protegidas a riesgo de dañar las
y poner en peligro la fauna local esta
práctica ha sido criticada y el pasado
mes de octubre el vídeo de una cabra
salvaje que murió de agotamiento tras
ser perseguida por un 4x4 provocó un
escándalo a diresa ya dar y es una
activista medioambiental en teherán este
tipo de accidente en el que las personas
participan en un safari vengan no es
salvaje y lo persiguen ocurre a menudo
estoy en las plantas matan a los
insectos a los roedores y también a los
gatos de arena todas las especies que
viven justo bajo las dunas en los
últimos cinco años este fenómeno de los
safaris no ha hecho más que aumentar
la razón principal es que estas zonas
son vírgenes mientras siguen siendo
desconocidas para el público en general
manda que dar amor la mayoría de los
desiertos están en peligro especialmente
los de javier mar y mar and hub que es
de fácil acceso
esta gente cree que no hay nada vivo en
estos desiertos cuando en realidad pasan
por encima de seres y organismos vivos
y terminamos con la noticia falsa de la
semana que pueden encontrar en nuestra
cuenta de instagram analizamos un vídeo
que dice mostrar que la nieve se quema
la explicación de este fenómeno con
nuestro reportero tristán work master
manipulación del clima la nieve no se
quema
por la ola de frío que atraviesa europa
a una antigua noticia falsa negacionista
resurgió entre el 'gran vemos a un
hombre recogiendo en nieve fuera de su
casa y le mandó la en su estufa muy bien
miremos si la nieve se quema no debería
quemarse porque es agua
porque se quema la miel
en primer lugar porque la nieve no pasó
a su estado líquido veamos el
experimento que hizo esta química porque
lo que pasa con la nieve es que puede
pasar por un proceso que se llama
sublimación así que puede pasar de un
estado sólido a un estado gaseoso cuando
se expone a mucho calor pero entonces
porque es en negrete la nieve
eso también es química no es por la
nieve ni por lo que contiene sino por
las impurezas del gas que genera este
depósito de carbono oloroso por último
cómo se explica que se encienda nos
pusimos en contacto con un físico la
nieve por sí sola no puede quemarse así
que necesariamente hay algo en la nieve
que fue introducido voluntaria o
involuntariamente
voluntariamente lo intente con azúcar
tuve el mismo efecto de la llama que
este señor por otro lado podría ser
involuntariamente alguna basura que
estuviera en el parapeto resulte madera
plástico papel etcétera
y claro que no pudimos analizar la nieve
de este vídeo pero todo lo que se ve en
la pantalla tiene una explicación
científica así que cuidado cuando vean
un titular sensacionalista esperen antes
de compartir el vídeo
esto es todo en los observadores por
esta semana si quieren escribir a
nuestro equipo todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla esperamos sus fotos
y videos para cubrir juntos la
actualidad internacional en imágenes de
aficionado hasta pronto